job well our senior island correspondent
david blevins joins us now
i mean look i mean the big question here
david is is this finally going to bring
some stability some much needed
stability to the dup
well sir jeffrey certainly has his work
cut out for him on that front
he is the dup's fifth leader in the
party's 50-year history but the third
in this space of two months arlene
foster was ousted they felt she wasn't
taking a tough enough line against the
brexit protocol
edwin putz was ousted after just three
weeks basically for the same reason
they felt he shouldn't have nominated a
first minister without
obtaining some concessions from the
prime minister
on the brexit protocol so it was always
blindingly obvious
that sir jeffrey was going to demand
some movement
on that issue of the trade border in the
irish sea before recommitting the party
to power sharing here at stormont
in his first statement as leader
designate he talks about the importance
of this place he says
it's where every element of society is
represented where every voice is heard
but the partnership
must be based on mutual respect and he
continues
i will be speaking with the prime
minister at the earliest opportunity
to emphasize that it is not realistic to
expect stability
when every unionist representative in
the devolved institutions
opposes the northern ireland protocol
the government
and those who claim to be protectors of
peace and stability
must step up and deal with the protocol
in a manner which represents the
constitutional
and economic integrity of the united
kingdom
so he's spelling out his agenda very
clearly there
but when paul gibbon who was edwin puts
nominee for first minister last week
resigns as he's expected to
sir jeffrey will have just seven days to
seek some sort of concession from boris
johnson
or risk a collapse of power sharing in
the snap election
but remember this is the man who
negotiated the famous confidence and
supply deal one billion pound deal with
the tories back in 2017
so he knows how to do business